those moments of struggle uh where you
are pushed and steel sharpen steel and
pressure creates Diamond those are
fundamentally uh important because those
are the moments of real deep personal
transformation they argue that there's
no such thing as objectivity and truth
and they place a theoretical and
philosophical Primacy on epistemology
how we know what we know they move away
from an ontology what actually exists
there's no such thing as truth
objectivity or science and therefore
everything is about contestation power
power what you see is what I call a
trauma Shield a trauma bubble it's now
become a weapon in order to shut people
up yeah on the campus you can have these
ideas uh but when they spill out you can
begin to see the human costs of some of
this stuff and we're doing this in the
context of an increasingly multi-polar
International System as an influence
operation a psychological operation I'm
not saying it's all rest of the heat the
feet of Chinese or Russian propagandists
the idea that there's not influence in
psychological warfare taking place is
for the birds trust
[Music]
me hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin kiss and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People Our Guest today is a professor of
International Security at the University
of exor and a fellow at the Council on
geost strategy and Senior adviser at The
legatum Institute he writes about
American foreign policy geopolitics and
the culture wars and his writing has
appeared in the Del Telegraph the times
the critic The Spectator and many other
outlets his latest book is called
against decolonization campus culture
wars and the decline of the West Doug
Stokes welcome to trigonometry thank you
very much it's great to have you on the
show we're going to talk about the
decline of the West a favored theme on
on this show as always uh which pleases
both of us for different reasons um but
before we do tell us a little bit about
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us uh well I I was born BR in
London in East London hack East London
lived there for 24 years I then left the
UK for about a year I lived and worked
in uh in Bosnia quite close to the just
after the war finished I lived in a
place called brido in Northern Bosnia
it's still a very contested space
I lived there for about a year joined
two halves of what was called was still
is the Republic of CSA so I lived there
for a year uh and then I came back I
lived in the west country I was at
Bristol University my master and PhD at
Bristol University then I moved around
the UK quite a lot so that that that's
my kind of per obviously it's potted
history that's my personal history uh
and now I'm a professor at University of
EX I've been there for 10 years uh and I
do various other things work on lots of
different projects the new book's
obviously out and I'm also a seni
advisor to The latam
Institute and uh one of the things we
were Keen to talk with you about is
essentially the question that we like to
throw at all of our guest is what's
going on Doug what's going on what's
going on yeah what's going on wow okay
what's going on well well what I'll do
is I'll I'll link it back to the book of
course you will you're here to promote
the book well I'm no I'm here to have
conversation with you two I mean that's
that's that's important thing for me but
so the book makes a sets of AR different
sets of arguments that I mean what what
what motivated me to write that book was
uh you know I've always seen
universities somewhere where we can have
open and rational debate and open
inquiry in an Ideal World at least uh
and really universities are sort of the
sort of the motors of human civilization
you know you contestation you can have
these incredible ideas taking place so
wonderful cultural centers of of really
but what I what I really really found
was over the last sort of uh sort of
there's been a period of time especially
over the last five years and especially
after you know post George Floyd there
was a sort of increasingly creeping IL
liberalism and authoritarianism on the
campuses uh manifested around various
types of issues uh and in in particular
this kind of idea of of De
decolonization and decolonizing the
curriculum uh which itself is kind of
quite contested ideology it draws from
uh a specific sets of theories post
structuralism postmodern postcolonialism
but it was increasingly being imposed by
University
authorities uh and executive teams and I
thought that that was a grave threat to
our universities and
to Liberal values of pluralism and
openness and uh and free inquiry so so
the book is really about that process it
looks at the the ways in which uh
there's been these kind of increasingly
moral panics within Western politics and
the ways in which uh what I sort of
identify as sort of professional
managerial Elites technocratic Elites
you you put those in in those kind of
terms have often sort of latched on to
to this and a sort of a politics of
vulnerability uh where they're they're
enabled to sort of control the narrative
to some extent but also to to to to lead
alleged oppressed uh minorities Etc to
some sort of technocratic solution or
salvation and and the power ultimately
rests with them so the looks at that and
then it unpacks some of the theories
some of the philosophical ideas of that
then relates it I'm very keen to relate
to much bigger a much bigger this is why
I asked you what's going on because
everything you've said so far will be a
very familiar story to our audience
these are questions we've been looking
at for for several years now but what
what I found interesting about your work
in your book is that you talk about the
bigger picture what's going on that's
these things are more of a symptom of
rather than just being being the problem
itself so what is at the core of
everything that's
happening in terms of the the the kind
of the broader culture War well there's
multiple levels that you can analyze it
right so I I think the one of the first
big things we need to understand is that
uh what takes place in in popular
culture or in our life here in in the UK
many of it draws from much deeper
philosophical currents and I think I
find it very frustrating people that
talk about the culture or a lot uh
essentially I see it those discussions
about specific issues you know diversity
manages in in the National Health
Service or you know various cultural
issues you really I I find it
frustrating because you're ultimately
talking about a sort of tactical
elements of a much broader cultural and
philosophical Mala which is what well so
what what is it so essentially what I
would say is the Wellspring of a lot of
this stuff comes from various
theoretical elements that we've seen
developing in the humanities and social
sciences in the anglophone universities
in particular over the last 20 to 30
years so what what you what you
ultimately had is um essentially you had
a critique of uh uh uh western
civilization and in particular you had
post structuralist and postmodernist
philosophers so Michel Fuko Jac derar
Edward S I'm sure you're familiar with
with those kind of those thinkers and
the essential critique that they made
and and they move away and it's also a
direct attack attack on Marxism which is
quite interesting because often some of
the analysis says that the culture wars
are kind of a Neo Marxist thing but in
many senses in the book tries to draw
this out it's also it's also a radical
critique of Marxism Marxism minimally at
least had a theological view of History
it was kind of an arc of progress and it
was a materialist philosophy it's rooted
in material structures and and a notion
of the world an ontological realism are
the world exists and we can come to
understand it and therefore transform
the world so post structuralist
ultimately critique that they argue that
there's no such thing as objectivity and
truth and they place a theoretical and
philosophical Primacy on epistemology
how we know what we know they move away
from an ontology what actually exists so
so I think on a metap philosophical
almost a transcendental level in western
civilization in the anglophone world at
least that has been one of the big
cultural shifts we've seen there's been
a conveyor belt process of graduates
being educated in these ideas that have
then come out into broader culture and
so and the essential argument is is a
social places Primacy on social
constructivism essentially the the real
world doesn't exist reality doesn't
exist all reality is essentially are
sets of contested discursive or
iological constructs endlessly at war
with each other okay and so there's and
so there's no way of ultimately
adjudicating the truth between these
these different social constructs given
that there's no such thing as reality
and therefore all of human life is
characterized by this endless
philosophical struggle to impose one's
truth in other words if we're looking at
the background the set of the show and I
claim that the wall is made of brick and
you claim that it's made of I don't know
glue who is right or wrong isn't a
matter of the truth it's a matter of who
which of us has more power status
influence in current society and
therefore that person gets to impose
their will on everybody else exactly and
so and so in the book what I do is I
identify that social
constructivism as a fundamental
philosophical transcendental value that
is now at the heart of Western civil in
particular anglophone
civilization and and and so and that's
exactly what it argues there's no such
thing as truth or objectivity or science
and therefore everything is about
contestation power power and essentially
so uh if I so and and so that the the
decolonizing critique is that you had
colon Formal
colonialism uh extra territorial
acquisition and what's happened is uh in
western civilization today which which
is is fundamentally based upon Colonial
discourses that construct the world in
in in in in a kind of often as a duality
it draws on daed D it says there's a
there's a there's a dominant and as
subordinate there's the white black male
female yeah Western nonwestern
so and there's there's an inferiority
and a superiority which again dedar
completely contested all this stuff by
the way is fundamentally philosophically
contested it has very little veracity
interesting in and of itself no doubt
about that but anyway so so so it argues
that so that social constructivism has
really escaped the the campus petri dish
and now Spilled Out into broader culture
okay I in the book I argue that we have
to hang on to a sense of reality and I
argue for on ological realism scientific
realism and what I try to do in the book
is to sort of unpack that and relate
this to some of the big bigger issues
about
geopolitics and decolonizing and the
broader malays in Western culture and
essentially what it argues is we have to
re focus our uh philosophical or value
Primacy on what exists what is real yeah
so so consenting you may say that that's
made of brick and I may say it's made of
glue but because of the Mind independent
nature of that war you're more right
than me because it's on there is such a
thing as ontological reality fris you
may believe that you can fly you can you
can flap your arms and you'll be a bird
you can jump out of this window right
now and every single time you're going
to hit the deck don't be trans
specious you're going to hit the deck
and you're going to hit the deck because
there ontological reality of gravity in
other words there is a world that exists
independently of our consciousness
okay and because of that it creates a
boundedness on what is true and what's
not true in other words there's a
rational
adjudication you may believe that you
know earthquakes are the anger of the
gods or I may believe it but we know uh
that it's the it's the tectonic movement
of the plates of the earth do you see
what I mean so because of because of the
primacies placed on ontology or reality
that's why Kathleen Stock's book she's a
philosopher her subtitle was why reality
matters is a material reality so I argue
that we must return to basic values or
not in terms of imposition but we have
to ultimately return to the rational
adjudication of different claims as to
one's truth some are more true than
others otherwise we end up in that
social constructive stew of judgmental
relativism you can't have an opinion how
dare you have think that my truth is as
valid as your your truth you say it's
brick it's not brick that's a mere
imposition of your Colonial mindset on
me and who are you to say that to me my
truth is my truth I can Define who I am
I can be whatever I wish to be there's
no such thing as truth and your desire
to put that on me is a mere uh
imposition how dare you you see what I
mean so you begin to see so so that's a
big part of it of uh this the old cliche
politics is Downstream of culture you've
heard it hundreds of times no doubt
about that but that but that captures
something what what the the stew that we
stew through unconsciously not even
knowing it it's just
reproduced unconsciously often does come
from a much deeper philosophical
theoretical base conceptual base so
Western Civilization now I'll wrap up in
a couple of seconds Western Civilization
now is characterized by generic
judgmental relativism and social
constructivism which is fundament ly
antithetical to the values that came
before and I would argue some of the
values that really helped to progress
all of human
civilization Doug there's a lot to
unpick there but
firstly this is really dangerous and and
I'll give an explanation as to why um I
remember I think it was Clinton actually
I saw an interview uh with that non
problematic figure Bill Clinton he was
talking about uh peace talks between the
Arabs and the uh the Israelis and he
said the first thing is right we
disagree on everything here can we agree
that it's Monday and they went yeah yeah
we all agree with it's Monday the
problem is if you can't even agree that
it's
Monday then you're never going to come
to any type of agreement on the more
complex or important things exactly and
and and and so what that does is that
that's exactly right that foregrounds a
judgmental relativism it says there's no
such thing as truth and human
interaction is always is therefore
characterized is a classic Fuko Fuko ISM
human interaction therefore is always
characterized by a form of discursive
struggle uh human interact so
essentially it's always about the
imposition of power and knowledge and
truth I'm imposing my truth onto you so
you can really that once you understand
that concept you can really begin to
unpack a lot of what we see in in the
culture War there are other elements to
it of of course you know the the kind of
the weaponization of bureaucracy and
technocratic
regimes uh the complete incapacity of uh
so-called conservative party to even get
ahead of any of this or get its head
around it the generic sort of General
philosophical drift that we've seen uh
but it's very dangerous that these ideas
are quite dangerous because um on the
campus you can have these ideas uh but
when they spill out you can begin to see
the human costs of some of this stuff in
relation to what it does to social
relations the trans issue is a massive
one you you've seen a lot of lot of this
take place it's kind of almost a you
know the self-
identification you have that but then
there's also the bigger issue in
relation to what this means about the
future of Western civilization in the
context of an increasingly multi-polar
International System uh the rise of
China the rise of other
states you
know and those States aren't
characterized by that if we can agree
you might disagree with me here if we
can agree that one of the big
progressors of human civilization has
been uh arriving at a kind of a system
that we can might call the truth it's
never always going to be the truth but
it it's the best explanation that we
have at that point in time it might be a
medical breakthrough right and and and
and what happens and it's like standing
on the shoulder of giants from that
truth we can continue to our inquiry our
open rational inquiry to find a better
truth that when technological
breakthroughs for example happen we we
move forward you see what I mean if we
can never get to that Foundation
foundational place in any way it's
everything's a contestation everything's
a power struggle constantly we're never
going to advance you see what I mean
we're going to sort of almost collapse
into a into a relativist stew and again
in and you think about the rise of China
related geopolitics I'm sure we'll come
on to the talk a bit more about that in
a bit but if what has really helped uh
instantiate uh a broadly a kind of open
economic
system uh economic advancement
Innovation an increasingly multi-racial
and Multicultural societies that
predicated on liberal values of openness
and tolerance and pluralism if you
introduce this concept of constant
tribal discursive
Warfare that can do great damage to the
social contract but also to to politics
in general and you can begin to and and
in the context of the rise of Highly
authoritarian and highly illiberal
States that's a very very dangerous
thing because what we have in the west
is not natural we've had a in in Europe
minimally essentially we we've lived on
the institutional architecture of the
postwar international settlement the the
victory of the West First over Nazi
Germany and then over um communist
Soviet
Union those are contingent things
they're not there's no necessary
Progressive Arc in human history so the
in institutional settlements that arose
from those forms of Victory aren't
natural they have they they've been
imposed to some extent and they have to
be defended and in within those within
those things are sets of values that I
would argue broadly speaking are very
pro-human
values uh and but those aren't
necessarily the values other states
share and in and in a increasingly
multi-polar International System of
increased geop GE geopolitical
competition and great power competition
Interstate war and and the end of the
end of History we really should perhaps
be slightly more cognizant of the kind
of values that hold us together because
we're going to need them going to the
Future we're going to be at the Battle
of ideas on the 28th and the 29th of o
October in London the Battle of ideas is
a festival of free speech that happens
in London every year where you will see
some of your favorite guests from
trigonometry coming to London to take
part in debates not only that both
Francis and I will be
there I'll be taking part in the spike
podcast and also in a discussion about
online censorship and I'll be there
talking about mizy From Misery to online
civility I think that's the name of it
basically we're going to be talking
about myy and what horrible little so
and so he is yeah come along uh not just
for that but also because there'll be
lots of cool people there make sure to
say hello to us if you see us grab your
tickets today by going to the Battle of
ideas website and if you want a 20%
discount it's available to all our
supporters on local so if you're not
already there head on over subscribe get
your 20%
off the the woke argument that I am most
sympathetic to out of all of them is
lived experience because the reality is
we all have a different lived experience
if for instance you're a 5 fo one very
attractive woman in her early 20s your
experience in life is going to be very
different from me you're going to be
offered and given things and have
opportunities that I simply won't have
but also as well I'm not going to be you
know Vis intimidated by a bloke in a pub
pestering me and wanting to have sex
with me and not listening to No do you
see what I mean I do but so but I think
what you're saying there basically we
have our own viewpoints based on our
history and that that's that's an
entirely Fair Point absolutely
completely fair point but what I think
what again what a lot you you get you
tend to get this a lot in in often like
Progressive movements in particular you
get a nice little word like lived
experience or equality and who who just
like you know who can disagree but then
it becomes it's empty signifi that
becomes filled with something much more
often quite illiberal on authoritarian
so lived experience what you're
essentially saying is we all have our
own Viewpoint depending on where we come
from that's pretty yeah that that that's
that's that's kind of a fair point but
what but what lived experience has
become in real it's like communism it's
all about equality not quite so what
lived experience has become is uh a kind
of authoritarian power job in so far as
when I talk about my lived experience
that's my truth and how dare you
question my truth and you get that quite
a lot in in I've seen that a lot you
know so essentially what lived
experience is is as a as a kind of uh
operative power play concept is really
about it's about saying this is my lived
experience invariably from an
historically maligned or oppressed
minority and therefore I have greater
truth and greater Social Power you need
so therefore you need to shut up and
listen to me and basically do what I
want now I'm from a really poor
workingclass family in Hackney I'm you
know my demographic in terms of white
working class kids in University if I
start going around to people and say
well I'm from a poor working-class
family and I want this and you got to do
this because that's my lived experience
so lived experience is all well and good
but again essentially that you've got to
be cognizant of the the the the capacity
to instrumentalize these Concepts and
weaponize these concepts for power and a
lot of this stuff we see is all about
power about institutional power making
money and that kind of stuff so lived
experience is one of them you've seen us
now scientists talk about lived
experience for me it's one of those kind
of very odd flip authoritarian
totalitarian Concepts where essentially
it goes from what you said entirely fair
enough and then completely agree to
being shut up do what I say because I'm
an oppressed minority and that's my
lived experience and what you're saying
doesn't count yeah I've seen that time
and time again it is used and that's the
thing that I hate about it instead of it
being a point of a point of discussion
where someone can go look I understand
that but you need to understand that as
a black BL growing up in 1980s Brixton
yeah I was targeted I had you know I was
RAC I was denied
opportunities and we need to talk about
this and we need to be honest about this
instead it's like you said it's now
become a weapon in order to shut people
up yeah exactly and uh and and even then
one one hopes that if you're talking
about the lived experience to ultimately
open up human the human heart this is
what you're really talking yeah you're
saying I had this pain or I had this
oppression and I'm giving you my heart
here I'm lived experence my personal
experience then one would hope that that
rests on an openness and a human grammar
of compassion and empathy yeah which
yeah but so often it's not this is the
problem it becomes weaponized and
instrumentalized and I think I've see
this time and time again uh you know so
essentially as a it's not a cruel point
I'm making it but as a Ben point which
is B in the nice sense in terms of an
obvious Point lived experience personal
experience of course but but then when
that starts to become
a an operative value at the Apex point
of institutional
cultures then you're going wrong well
what you're talking about really is that
some Concepts can be misapplied if you
and I having a conversation about what
it's what it was like in 1980s Soviet
Union I can be well I actually grow up
there here's here's what my take on it
was but if we you and I were talking
about economic statistics about 1980
Soviet Union and you were saying to me
well did you know that blah blah I was
like well actually my lived experience
well that doesn't apply in the realm of
Statistics observable realities of that
kind Etc so I think sometimes it's just
a concept that as you say has been
expanded Way Beyond its remit and people
will use it to achieve ends that it
can't be used to aeve
yeah or or you or to stick with your
example you say I grew up in 1980 Soviet
Union and that was my lived experience
right and uh and I make oh no I don't
want you to speak because I'm that's my
experience and you know so what you what
what you what you see is what I call a
trauma Shield a trauma bubble you know
you sort of talk about it and again it
speaks to this kind of uh this this
politics of vulnerability and this sense
the weaponization of trauma we see as
well it's a very common thing and
victimhood
yeah and and the sad thing about that is
genuine you know VI it may it may well
be true but when it's when it's when
it's it's weaponized instrumentalized as
essentially a power play to for me to
say well yeah you you I I was born in
the 1980 Soviet Union and it therefore
it gives me I'm on a higher moral perch
than you to sort give you my truth and
it trumps your truth and and under that
then there's an an emotional power play
okay so let me chart this in simple
terms because I want to get from what
you're saying which is erosion of the
concept of Truth tribalism uh
accelerated by the very idea that we all
have our own unique perspective and mine
is more valuable than yours because I
have a certain blah blah blah to the
concerns you have about geopolitics and
geost strategy Etc right and so the idea
correct me on any of this is if I'm
incorrect is because Western societies
are increasingly divided along these AR
arbitrary lines between groups that are
drawn not by a contestation of what
reality actually is but simply about who
can make the most noise who can have the
greatest claim to victimhood who can
have the the biggest complaint whatever
it might be we actually can't agree
about what our values are and therefore
when we are engaging in the Battle of
civilizations or at least in
geopolitical competition we don't know
what it is that we stand for and so
we're living off the fumes of the values
that were created in the postwar period
that we no longer as a society actually
universally believe yeah I mean so think
about this right in terms if we take uh
this desire for uh diversity incl
inclusion and Equity so Equity uh is a
concept that obviously conflates
equality of opportunity which is a
completely optimal way of running
Society in many sense is you want the
best people in in irrespective of their
sexuality their gender their race to get
as best chance as possible to then to
then move forward and ideally when you
aggregate that at the societal level
you're going to get great outcomes from
that so so that concept has really been
conflated and collapsed into equality of
outcome where essentially you get uh
often technocratic Elites who who will
essentially engineer and engender uh
forms of in inclusive cultures to make
sure everybody gets the same so that
that then is obviously in many senses
that that then is kind of fundamentally
antithetical to Western uh politics in
fact it's more it's more commensurate
ultimately the equality of outcome
argument to sort of Soviet sort of a
Soviet system this is why my next book
which I'm currently working on is why
the West lost the Cold War we thought we
won it in geopolitical terms but he lost
it in Co metaphysical terms so so so
that's fundamentally but and so
essentially so when you aggregate that
out to a so societal level where you
have technocratic Elites that are kind
of have taken it on their holy mission
to uplift people often people don't even
want it uh and and if you aggregate that
out at a society level where where
people are potentially doing jobs not
because they're the best people to do
the jobs or not because the most
qualified or or Etc I.E the diversity is
is is a sub variable of a much higher
Apex value which is one of Merit and
selection on the basis of Merit if
diversity becomes the Apex value in the
institutional selection process when you
aggregate that out I.E the the
intersectional characteristic of the
individual doing the job it becomes more
important than the capacity to do the
job well there was a brilliant article I
think the Magazine online Magazine's
called padium called why complex systems
won't survive the competence crisis and
it talks all about I really recommend
every read it it talks all about how
basically in America a lot of very
complex systems like Aviation safety and
the military Etc are actually being very
badly affected by these diversity
initiatives so so I mean so essentially
there's nothing wrong with diversity per
se in any way and there's nothing wrong
with inclusion in any way but but the
thing is th those things must be or if
those things must be ultimately outcomes
of a much more important process which
is the selection on the basis of
capacity and Merit the problem is with
the AR with that argument Doug is that I
don't know that that is possible because
not all groups have the same talents uh
aspirations skill sets and that has been
true throughout history so uh some
diversity will be a natural consequence
of selection on competence but I also
think we have to recognize that not all
people want the same things or are good
at the same things and so divers
I am increasingly persuaded by the
argument that artificially created
diversity is not a good thing but the
but the other also I completely agree
with your point the other thing about
that is often uh the equity quality of
outcomes thing again it underplays or
completely erases human agency and
therefore human dignity yes if you got a
squirrel I'm going to give a really bile
example here if you got a squirrel that
goes out in the winter or in the summer
and gathers all the nuts up and and puts
it all way you know h it away and works
hard and then another one sits there
just sunbathing and smoking or blunt or
whatever squirrel whatever whatever
right how fair is it then if you go
along to the the school number a that
saved up the nuts and say well you know
what our friend over here has got no
nuts now it's winter now it's cold and
shivery give me half your nuts to give
the him I mean that's not that's not so
so in other words human agency people's
choices uh application self-discipline
and hard work are really also
fundamental value so in many senses this
kind of woke dispensation we'll put it
in true terms it raises the the the the
innate Dignity of human agency and it
erases the incentive to create build
strive achieve which is what you're
talking about when it comes to
geopolitics so so so so when we go back
to your original question about
geopolitics if some of the uh the it's
very much about values and metaphysical
almost transcendental values we put on
those kind terms if we've had the
subversion of the transcendental or the
metaphysical values of Western
Civilization where new sets of values
are replacing the old
ones and that's we we then aggregate
that at a societal level a
civilizational level and we're doing
this in the context of an increasingly
multi-polar International System the
rise of incredibly powerful
civilizational states that have
extraordinary sense of of nationalist
purpose national
pride also feed off uh a decolonizing
narrative and also now spreading around
the world and as an influence operation
a psychological operation I'm not saying
it's all rest of the heat the feet of
Chinese or Russian propagandists but the
idea that there's not influence in
psychological warfare taking place is
for the birds trust me trust me on that
so why do you say why should people
trust you on that day I I've I've worked
in the security intelligence military
Fields academic fields for many many
years my PhD was on C Insurgency Warfare
for goodness sake psychological
operations I'm not you know I'm not you
know it's not and it's and why wouldn't
they do that of course they do it and
there's nothing wrong with it if you
think about it in terms of this is
basically great power politics this is
this is my bread and butter great power
great power competition is my bread and
butter and states will States will do
what states do right in their national
interests or national security interests
of course China using its incredible
economic leverage with belt and Road
initiative is running all over the
Caribbean investing tens of billions of
of dollars in the Caribbean
infrastructure projects and of course
they're going to say you need you know
reparations against the colonial Masters
and to to sort create this uh soft power
of course and you know what that that's
that's natural and normal I mean States
will will engage in psychological op
operations and warfare but coming back
to the other so we come on but come back
if we then think that what we have in
the west isn't natural we didn't just
roll out a bed with a panina clader and
a nice sort of international no not much
War here is is there not been invaded
since 1066 because we're an island
stopping power of water Etc but none of
this is natural right and it rests on an
international dispensation an
international order underpinned by
American Power American military power
in particular Ukraine would be most
probably singing from the Russian
national anthem absent the very early
intervention of the Brits but in
particular the Americans right I mean
that's really so America Remains the key
lynchpin power in in the in the broader
liberal it's called the liberal
International order if it keeps being
characterized by this process of
denigration and being torn
apart uh you do have these very capable
States out there and human history is
doesn't doesn't doesn't just rest some
way it's constant process of flux and
change so that comes to the big point of
the book don't take what we have for
granted I mean it sounds really TR to
say it but Freedom isn't free Freedom
isn't free it has to be defended and
loved and cherished cherished and it
just being nice to people being kind is
not enough unfortunately you need people
like me and
others sort of to some extent you know
you know or to sort of guard against
stuff uh and that what we have is to
some extent under the outer edges of it
most people don't see it rest on a hard
power basis you have a you know you know
you're on Russia and Ukraine you see it
really brutally there uh great power
competition and the fields of Ukraine is
very raw and we see it in the flesh
there you see what I mean so that's a
really big thing and so I try to tie it
all together in the book we have to see
this stuff in a much broader
civilizational context but Doug you made
a really good point which is it uh
Freedom needs to be defended loved and
cherished my
issue I don't think there's enough
people in this country there's more in
America but there's not enough in this
country who defend love and cherish it
and once that happens we're in a pretty
paress State aren't
we that's a great point I
mean a depressing point for me was
during the
pandemic uh there is by the way Doug
this is what I do in the in the in in
this show I just make everyone miserable
he killed the vi this what I used to do
in my youth and I do it now it's great
so essentially so you know the I think
the British there the kind of cultural
DNA of the Brit p acious there's an
element to the British culture don't
like doesn't like to be told what to do
there is this kind of almost innate DNA
of Freedom there you know you can trace
it back and people take take the Mickey
out of it but know Magna carter and
there's that you know standing up
against Nazi Germany standing up against
communism there is that kind of very
strong sense in the British people but
on the flip side of that there is also
that finger wagging and follow the rules
and the curtain twitching so I found the
pandemic to be really really depressing
because it really bought out that
element that's that that that part of
the British
character moral policing and you know
dobbing in your neighbor and stuff like
that and then we saw we saw that uh in
British politics you know with the
conservative party I think the
conservative party I hate to say it but
I think they they do bear a large chunk
of responsibility because I just don't
think they quite get the what the stakes
that are
involved uh in in this and if if if this
rests if if if the ultimate meta value
of a conservative party is is the
preservation of a specific
civilizational dispensation they've
really dropped the ball on that well the
only Mo the only objective of the
conservative party at the moment is a
preservation of the conservative party
and they're not even doing that very
well no no it's an endless Psycho Drama
go if you want to stick just quick point
about carry on sorry I didn't mean to no
no not not at all but I mean um but I
mean this is also the frustration of is
is that you people say that the
conservative part weaponizing the
cultural war and they're using the
cultural War as a kind of like weapon to
divide divide the working class or the
my thing is it's complete nonsense uh
the conservative party as far as I can
tell on the culture war and utterly
strategically clueless I give an example
of it right in the last three months of
the Blair government okay they passed
the equality Act
now the equality Act is a really
Innovative piece of legislation but what
it essentially does uh is it mandates
public sector bodies National Health
Service any public sector body to to
promote equality of opportunity between
people of protected characteristics
sexuality gender so it sound it sounds
you know Progressive and you know but
what that's actually done is it's
underwritten the massive growth of EDI
bureaucracies across the public sector
so you still today there headlines today
you know or you know about the woke
civil service right so you have that uh
uh across the British public sector and
it legally mandates public sector bodies
to promote equality of opportunity now
what's the metric for equality of
opportunity
outcome so you get all these EDI
bureaucracies the commissars in the
public sector the woke commissar if you
want use crude language who have used
the the Innovations around the equality
act to push this stuff through so it's a
constant frustration of mine to see
these headlines in the Daily Mail Daily
Telegraph or wherever constant cultural
War whack-a-mole headlines about the
cultural oh isn't it terrible diversity
manag isn't this is that and yet and yet
these public sector bodies quite rightly
can turn around and say well it's our
it's our legal duty to do this so the
idea that the touris been fighting a
culture War when they've they've left
this on the books left for them like a a
a a grandm chess board the last three
months of the Blair government and have
left it completely unreformed and then
the pernicious and authoritarian liberal
elements of that act you know the
unconscious bias the microaggressions
all this stuff we see that all comes
from that act too why because one of the
ways in which Employers in the public
sector can to discharge their Duty under
under under the equality Act is to say
well we've run these training programs
and all of our employees have gone
through these training programs and
therefore we we've discharged our duty
you see what I mean so all the percious
pernicious elements of that act you I've
got I've gone off a little bit there
from geopolitics but it just it just
underlines the point about we have to
understand the deeper tactical and
strategic terrain upon which a lot of
this stuff that we talk about in the
culture wars and geopolitics it rests on
a much deeper
infrastructure do you have a website or
do you plan to have a website because if
you do then easy DNS is a company for
you easy DNS is the perfect domain name
regist our provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients whether it be cancel
culture deplatform attacks or
overzealous government agencies he knows
about that so we you in a second easy
DNS have Rock Solid Network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that move
your domains and websites over to
easydns right now all you've got to do
is go to easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com SLT triggered use our promo code
which is also triggered and get 50% off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and
censorship but it also speaks to just a
lack of common sense it's just a
complete lack of Common Sense if you're
not going to get the best person for the
job the job isn't going to be done as
well if you're going to get rid of
meritocracy the whole industry is going
to crumble because you are not going to
be doing the job that you're meant to be
doing as
effectively nothing nothing's going to
work I don't understand why this is a
particularly difficult point to grasp
well I think again I think you're
absolutely you've hit the nail on the
head but the dangerous thing about that
is uh by being inclusive and be kind and
be empathetic which is underpinning a
lot of the drive for that stuff which is
wonderful it sounds great it's a
wonderful thing right that it's it's the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions if again if you if you
aggregate that out across a societal
level you're going to have suboptimal
outcomes inbuilt into institutional
cultures time and time and time again
and when you aggregate that out that the
quality of your life the functioning of
your
services uh the way your money as
taxpayers is spent will constantly be
suboptimal and it goes back to my
original point in the context of great
power
competition do you do you think for one
second that the the Chinese who are an
incredible civilization thousands of
years of history I mean what an what an
incredible country what incredible
culture it's just amazing but you know
they do you really think they are going
to be saying Little Johnny didn't pass
his exam but we'll give him the job
anyway or you know or or we're gonna it
basic we want to make our kids feel
better so everybody's going to get a
gold star here it just doesn't work does
it so that's not happening so if we have
this kind of broader Western Malay kind
of America which is the key key lynchpin
state in the western Le International
System we need America's military power
intelligence Powers all that kind of
stuff right if it's fractured along
these increasingly tribal lines and in
the context of increasingly economic
power shifting a multi-polar
International System the collapse of
Western self-confidence the collapse of
Western civilization in terms of the the
values that have made it successful made
it uh so strong and the best place
really for genuine diversity for
tolerance for pluralism for openness for
Liberal values yeah there's a reason why
millions of people come to W to the West
it's the
benefits well it's the benefits B
absolutely no but it's the benefits of
the the the deep that we have an
emphasis and a privacy placed on human
dignity the capacity for freedom to
allow you to realize your dreams yeah
everybody's always going to win a gold
star but broadly speaking what other uh
part of the world where where else would
you want to live where else would any uh
minority wish to live in human history
is it perfect of course it's not but
it's not a million miles from you know
it's pretty good pretty good Doug how
much of this is about um feelings
because you mentioned you know the CH
Little Johnny in China isn't being
praised for getting a
d but here little Johnny is being
praised for the effort that he put in to
get a d and you know I have a young son
and my wife and I sort of argue about
this all suddenly we don't argue but we
it's a constant ongoing conversation
because on the one hand yes you want
your children to grow up feeling happy
and they made the effort and blah blah
blah on the other hand as we talked
about the wall is either made of brick
or it's not and you either got an A or
you didn't and your civilization is
either successful or it's not and your
military is either capable of fighting
or it's not how much of this is about
the the obsession with our own constant
Obsession about our well-being and our
emotional well-being because some of the
most meaningful things I've done in my
life have been
created and done in spite of periods
when I've had to suspend my immediate
feelings about how I feel in this moment
and go and do something that's difficult
or go and do something that's unpleasant
or go and do something that's hard yeah
right yeah so how much of it is about
that well I I understand the struggle
that as a parent you feel I am a parent
uh as well and that is you want to
nurture and love your children uh and
you you it's a fine line between making
sure Little Johnny's feelings aren't too
hurt and you protect their precious
self-esteem and you love them so much
but between also exposing them to to
values that are real independently of
where we may be in our civilization or
moment they just are the values Ultimate
Reality Bites in that sense right so so
but I think I completely agree with your
broad point and that is I'm the same I
mean I uh feel anxiety a lot I I uh you
know uh
feel i' I've felt like my my periods of
most intense growth have become have
come when I've been put under incredible
pressure I won't go too personal but I
mean but it's so you know I used to have
uh uh somebody was close to me
academically senior to me that that
supervised me I won't go too much into
it and he was brutal absolutely brutal
he would give it he' tear it down
really brutal but in and he sort of tore
me down but then but in that process I
grew as an adult you see what I mean so
there's a so psychological a lot of
stuff is placed on psychological safety
and we need this right but what we're
doing ultimately is what ultimately uh
makes you grow become an adult and uh uh
really Thrive internally spiritually
almost right are those are those moments
of struggle deep struggle deep emotional
struggle I I say I was born in Hackney I
went to some schools in a city schools
you couldn't begin to imagine maybe you
could from the former Soviet Union I
don't know I think yours were a lot
worse I'm talking about guns if you're
talking about safety like the Soviet
Union was actually pretty safe yeah my
my schools were characterized by
constant violence knives CS gas guns
guns uh it was it was terrible right uh
so and a lot of my peer group are dead
or in prison or you know whatever right
so that that was that
um and so but the way I've tried to deal
with it I don't get too autobiographical
here but those moments of
struggle uh where you are pushed and
steel sharpens steel and pressure
creates Diamond those are fundamentally
uh important because those are the
moments of real deep personal
transformation th those are the moments
where you think you are who you are and
that transforms you and it mangles you
but you come out on the other side and
you're different but different often in
a good way agreed yeah I think that is
such an important point and it was
something that I wanted to talk to you
about and look we can bemoan these ideas
we can talk about the universities and
all of it is
relevant but to me that's just a symptom
that's just a symptom of the fact
that we've become softer as a society we
just have and therefore we're more prone
to these ideas because actually if we
had a little bit of backbone and we said
to put it in colloquial terms no I don't
believe this I think it's a lot of
bollocks piss
off yeah well absolutely I mean at the
same time I'm not arguing I mean where I
came from was brutal mhm in the home and
outside the home and I never ever wished
anybody to experience that so I'm not
arguing that for a second and I I'm also
not taking saying there's any great
shakes in having that level of
dysfunction no way and as a parent you
know you know You' never wish that upon
your children so that's categoric not
what I'm saying but but what I am saying
is I I I think that uh we do need to uh
move back to resilience some degree of
personal resilience and what I think
as the broader point we can take from
this is what I find very distressing is
when
institutions led by adults that should
know better yeah don't then draw the
line in the sand of what you've just
said or what uh Constantine has just
said they count how they collapse
because they don't want to hurt the
feelings of these people okay but see
this is and I'm exploring this with you
I'm not arguing with you it's just
something I'm thinking about myself
because I'm sure you've seen this thing
about how Hard Men create good times
good times you know create weak men weak
men create hard times and it goes round
and round round and the problem I see
the way that we all talk about it is my
childhood wasn't easy either and my
wife's childhood wasn't easy either and
neither of us wants to create that
childhood for my son right but if he's
going to have a really comfortable happy
existence where every need is taken care
of and he's never upset and he's praised
for the effort at school and and his mom
all of that
then he's going to become weak and it's
inevitable how do you build resilience
without being challenged without having
that difficulty would be the
counterargument I I think you need to
challenge your son and and and not not
going to make it person but one needs to
challenge obviously it's it's the con
strugle though isn't it we do live I
mean the the childhood I had yeah you
couldn't I mean you want to replicate
now there's different sets of values and
I think that is to be celebrated to some
extent I'm
not I I
think I'm not saying the hardness in
terms of physical but that's not what I
mean Francis what's that quote you you
talk about the boxer who says it's hard
to all right it's the old Jack Dempsey
quote which is it's it goes it's very
hard to get up and train at 5:00 in the
morning when you're wearing silk boxes
yeah when you sleep sleep on silk sheets
this is my point is is it I almost start
to wonder whether the decline of the
West is inevitable because we are so
successful we are so comt
you think think about you know the
ukrainians now for example are sending
their young men to go and fight and be
maimed and die on the front yeah if you
live a life where you're going to live
to a 100 yeah you you're going to have
every material creature Comfort taken
care of you know the latest polling
shows most of the country thinks that
the government's job is literally to
provide everything for them and wipe
their bottom or
whatever why would why would you why
would I send son to go and fire in the
front line why he can live to 100 have
everything he needs right why why would
any of us do that why would we fight for
anything well I I think a couple of
things I think that first and foremost I
think that whilst I don't wish to
denigrate that the love that lays at the
heart of that that that what we're
talking about and it is it is love yeah
really uh I don't wish to denigrate for
a second but to sort of draw it slightly
out of the personal around a bit more
and relate it back to the bigger
arguments what I would say is this it
goes back to my institutional point and
that is we've swung too far that way I'm
not saying we need less love or but we I
think what's happened in the west is we
got too comfortable but we've got too
comfortable in that process we've
forgotten the the the the the the
fundamental values that we need to
sustain ourselves right you see what I
mean I do but what I'm saying to you is
is that I wonder whether it's possible
because if we are so successful and so
comfortable uh and so protective of our
children and so on I'm not saying we
need less love for our kids at
all why would they be strong why would
they be uh willing to deal with conflict
because that's part of what we're
talking about right is willing to be
able to put something valuable on the
line to risk life and limb to protect
what you have but if you've always had
it if if your parents have always had
you don't even recognize the connection
anymore yeah this is where I think the
West is so my concern is you talked
about how those formative experiences
are often quite difficult and
challenging and traumatic I don't know
that you're going to get young people
people even our generation to wake up to
that reality without a really big hard
slap in the face well
I I completely agree what you just said
but I I think that
uh reality sometimes bites so it's it's
that's that's a hard thing you're right
I mean on the one hand we have a a very
comfortable uh existence uh on the one
hand even on on an absolute level or
relative levels you know in in in in the
UK so we have that but at the same time
you know you want to sort of maintain
some degree of uh the these these things
so I mean it's a very hard question to
answer because on the one on the one
hand we uh we have what we have
uh but then we need to sort of I guess
it's kind of like what you'd think it's
kind of not the best metaphor but
imagine that we have a shotgun in in a
cabinet a Dusty old cabinet
somewhere and we keep that for our sort
of home protection and there's cobwebs
all over it but nonetheless we still
prize it and we take it out of the
cabinet every now and again we all it
down like a very precious thing it's the
it's the the last line of defense ultim
we live in you know
but we keep it there and it's cobw and
we we thank goodness we never ever have
to use this this thing but nonetheless
we still are cognizant that it's there
it's an anchor point for us it's it's
it's our
final so so I think I think maybe
therefore then a greater
awareness of those values a I think
maybe a philosophical reboot of the
value of Western civilization and some
of the values that have sat at the heart
of his success I would also like to see
you know at the same time I I'm not
against this kind of the parenting that
we've discussed but I would I would I
think that what's happened it goes back
to my institutional point there has been
a complete moral failure and the
collapse of leaders and adults in our
dominant institutions where they they
have ultimately in the name of being
kind and uh being
inclusive not held the line or not even
not hold the line they've literally
thrown themselves onto the floor and and
gone like that uh the Church of England
being a classic example but across you
know the National Trust all our all of
our institutions seem to wish to uh
genuflect and deconstruct themselves and
ultimately repudiate the very nature of
Western
civilization and I think this is this
comes to another big point and that is
the kind of potential backlash that that
kind of institutional signaling can
create in the UK we're seeing it now as
some polling recently about sort of
issues around trans issues we're seeing
it in in in the politics of America too
and and so whilst these institutions
think they're doing God's will or you
know or deconstructing on this this sort
of
thing that they they I think that
they're potentially storing up a great
deal of trouble down the line
potentially for British politics because
it it it does rest on a script of
national repudiation the undermining of
ins utions the constant belittling of
Ordinary People you saw in the brexit
debates for example all the time uh and
it so so that's another element too that
I think we should be aware of and it's
also as well the absence of
leadership we it seems that we
completely devoid of leaders and it's
not just in politics if you read about
sport there'll be there's people that in
sports saying it's more and more
difficult to find captains to find
leaders because it doesn't seem that
anybody wants to take on that mantle
because people collapse they crumble at
the first s of criticism but this is
what I'm saying guys this is kind of my
point is we can blame institutions we
can blame the people at the top of
sporting organizations but if you have
generations of people coming
through who've been trained to think in
a particular way who've been trying to
think that their feelings matter more
than reality who've been trying to think
uh by the exper erences around them not
not because someone a woke teacher is
indoctrinating them but they've grown up
from from the age of three with
everything that they need catered to why
would they be resilient but that but
that's why I think that there has been a
failure on on on multiple levels not
least in the universities universities
when I first started for example was
were somewhere where uh still kind of
very late teen brain children 18 but
still young would go and and would in
and would be subject to those to sort of
very strong critical debate push pushing
them pushing them outside the comfort
zone being exp exposed to a broad set of
ideas contested it it was much more sort
of politically uh uh heterogeneous as
well 20 odd years ago and those kind of
values I spoke about were more in the
University context there was a there was
a sense that you go to university and
you're pushed hard right so so so I
think that there's various reasons why
universities have moved from that model
to being essentially a sort of
continuation of school and and therefore
the kind of modification but also the
diversity inclusion I mean that often
revolves around issues around
self-esteem and making people feel good
right rather than pushing people outside
their comfort zone so they grow they
grow as people they grow as adults which
is ultimately truly liberational is it
not uh so I think in the University
context that that has really fallen down
so if if we think that there are kind of
transmission points in one's maturing
journey in terms of what you've said so
your son is you know you L and but then
the sets of Institutions that he he will
move through is a process of maturation
that maturation process I think has been
lost to quite a large extent and
universities have really dropped the
ball on that dog have you ever been
punched in the face I've had my nose
broken about 11 times right and so have
I I've been I've been punch in the face
I've been beating up whatever else only
someone who has never been punched in
the face would use a sentence like words
of violence yeah and that comes from
someone who has had a completely modic
coddled life because if you have been
punched in the face you will know that
words are not violent someone's saying
something nasty about you is not the
same as having your nose broken and I
think that's at the very Crux of what
we're talking about here absolutely well
that because that draws on what we spoke
about at the very beginning if you
believe that uh there's no such thing as
truth and uh words have the capacity to
conjure into being a reality socially
construct reality if I talk about uh uh
something and it's in subjectively
agreed upon that thing becomes real
right so for people that are saying
words are violence they are
unconsciously implicitly or explicitly
invariably implicit ly drawing from a
deeper philosophical value set that
comes from that kind of deconstructivist
poststructuralist socially
constructivist epistemology theory of
world of of Truth words are violence
into to their theoretical perspective
because by saying this you're bringing
into being the reality of it you're
narrating that into being it's complete
garbled nonsense but that's that's their
position so for them but I completely
agree that is your I mean the the
realism of actually getting punched in
the face getting your nose broken or
whatever versus that but then again I
guess that speaks to the kind of the
diance again it's perhaps an overused
metaphor you often hear this about the
late days of Rome right where there'd be
crossdressing and mass orgies and sexual
degeneracy and and all this stuff taking
place and essentially the argument is
you know you they're at such a
comfortable point and then the elites
the institutions and the the the the
marital Valor and the honor the
integrity was lost and it became
increasingly they were bored they had
this luxury the elites had this
aristocratic and the elites the the
Roman people had this luxury decadence
decadence and they started is a frippery
and before you know it the barbarians
are through the gate and people in
inside Rome maybe have opened up the
gate to let the Barbarians in it's oh
it's all fun it's a it's a wonderful
joyous occasion we're being inclused or
whatever don't want extend the metaphor
too far but you see what I mean I
completely I completely agree well on
that happy note we're going to wrap up
this part of the interview Doug uh we're
going to move to locals in a second and
ask you some questions from our audience
and continue the discussion as well
before we do though we always wrap up
this part of the interview with one
final question which is what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should
be o we covered it to some extent but
the one thing I think that we need to
think more about is the contingent and
fragile nature of where we are in the
west uh if there's one takeaway point I
try to do in the book and that is to say
that what we have in the west is not
natural it's a it's a it's an
Institutional outcome it's a social
outcome it's it rests on values and and
and the will to power to defend
it uh and it's not too bad it's really
not too bad so we need to
be cognizant the primary takeaway we
have to be cognizant of what we have in
the contingent and fragile and precious
nature of it and we throw it away we let
it destroy itself a great great
Peril Doug it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
the show follow us now on locals where
we're going to be asking Doug more
questions and some of your questions as
well see you there
guys so why why are you doing this why
are you put in your head above the
metaphorical
[Music]
parit